histoire de faire c'est très marrant
nous sommes en 1981 non non non mais dit
on et en 2012 sinon va pas combien
d'amis on sait qu'on en 2012 là je
raconte l'histoire nous sommes en 1991
et le jeune satoshi décide d'aller pitch
est une de ces idées incroyables un des
cadres d'une marque qui commence par
nine et qui finit par d'eau c'est ce que
nous allons vous raconter dans cet
épisode c'était vachement bien
bonjour bonjour donc alors allez-y
parler - petit peu de votre projet donc
de quoi ça parle
alors si des monstres des monstres mais
petit mais qui se battent entre eux vous
inventez la non entre pour bien savoir
qui sera le plus fort des monstres mais
petit mais gentils entre eux pas mal
voilà et alors donc parlez moi plutôt
des petits monstres
alors en fait dans mon univers où ça se
passe ils vivent dans nos poches mais
dans des boules sinon il griffe vous
savez comment c'est les monstres habitat
coûte cher mais gentil ok donc ce serait
des petits monstres wii qui se battent
entre eux pour savoir lequel est le plus
fort est petit dans un monde où il n'ya
pas d'animaux sauf certains et ils
vivent dans des boules dans nos poches
les vêtements ça coûte cher
ok et alors comment les distingue j'ai
fait une liste ariely catégorie feu aux
20 plants électricité glace combat
poison sol vol petit insecte roche
spectre à gong ténèbres acier est normal
coop mal voilà et vous avez développé
les personnages des petits monstres
tu fais une liste de bulbizarre quoi air
bizarre
lorillard passé à l'âme mais assez
lennon dracaufeu d'accord je ne nie pas
ok avec vous le confort
rups sa boulette ni docking pas si
rennes miu miu
j'ai oublié quelque chose le truc le
plus important les petits monstres quand
il part ni ne parlent pas ils disent
leur nom par exemple racofier dracaufeu
traque au feu c'est la magie dit kalameh
jeté à la mer ni bouton edit les poteaux
ou les plus tôt vous avez fouiller dans
mes tiroirs
non vous avez fouiller dans mes tiroirs
du tout non mais non mais quelle musique
pardon je vous ai coupé pardon psycho
quoi qui dit quoi
aucune idée ok une psycho quoi qui
côtoie un ok alors j'ai tout bien
assimilé juste pour savoir comment ils
se comprennent du coup entre eux au
niveau de dialogue quand ils se parlent
pour comprendre simogo d'accord me
mygale messieurs mime germignon bon ben
c'est vachement bien
kangoo rex
tanguay by kaiminus et crémeux diggs
at-on ekra pantois pas tous les faire
mais le clic du bouton série bout doit
beaucoup non magneti manier zone et
c'est ainsi que la réunion durera
longtemps mais ça valait vraiment le
coup
en tout cas d'après des chaussettes chat
ou nantes où massa aux sorties pouilles
guina volts coloma sur la roc positif
claude lang vie grotte dino liés terra
klopp pikachu non ce n'est pas sûr